y
[Música]
la policía de hong kong detuvo al editor
jefe de cuatro directivos más del diario
pero democracia apple daily en el primer
caso de acusación por posibles violación
de la ley de seguridad nacional 500
agentes se incautaron material
periodístico y revisaron los teléfonos y
computadores portátiles de los
reporteros la organización mundial de la
salud bautizó como lambda a la hasta
ahora llamada variante andina de kobe 19
lambda de entra en las denominadas
variantes de interés y es responsable de
la mayor parte de los contagios en perú
y un tercio de los casos en chile y
argentina crece la alerta en nicaragua
donde ya son 16 los opositores detenidos
por diferentes acusaciones contra el
ejecutivo de daniel ortega entre los
capturados están pre candidatos a la
presidencia ex guerrilleros funcionarios
del sector privado y activistas que en
varios casos han denunciado abusos de la
policía en el momento de los arrestos
analizamos en esta emisión
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos este
informativo en hong kong 500 agentes de
la policía realizaron una redada al
medio prodemocracia a paul daily luego
de que las autoridades lo acusaron de
violar la ley de seguridad nacional por
una presunta conspiración para
confabular con fuerzas extranjeras cinco
ejecutivos del diario fueron arrestados
se trata del más reciente golpe contra
el magnate de los medios y fundador del
apple daily
jimmy ley uno de los más fuertes
críticos de beijing quien ya cumple
sentencia por participar en protestas no
autorizadas veamos más en el informe
bloqueando todas las entradas de las
oficinas de apple daily cientos de
policías hicieron redadas y arrestaron a
cinco ejecutivos del prominente diario
pro democracia de hong kong dentro de
ellos se incluyen al director ejecutivo
y al jefe de operaciones de next digital
dueño de apple daily también tres
editores el grupo fue arrestado por
presunta conspiración para confabular
con fuerzas extranjeras un delito
tipificado en la ley nacional de
seguridad respaldada por beijing e
impuesta en la ex colonia británica
puesto que a tal que conste verse en
watch estamos hablando de una
conspiración en la que los sospechosos
trataron de usar el trabajo periodístico
para confabularse con un país extranjero
o elementos externos e imponer sanciones
o tomar actividades hostiles en contra
de hong kong o tec obstat sentís tensión
con la policía también dijo que 2,3
millones de dólares en activos del
periódico fueron congelados este es el
primer embargo que se ordena
directamente en contra de una compañía
mediática apple daily es un medio que
combina el discurso prodemocracia con
chismes de celebridades e
investigaciones de los
es la segunda vez que las oficinas de la
publicación son allanadas lo que prende
las alarmas por el futuro de la libertad
mediática en hong kong el año pasado la
policía arrestó al fundador jean y ley
acusado de fraude y de violar la ley de
seguridad nacional la contenciosa ley
entró en vigor a finales de junio del
año pasado en respuesta a las masivas
protestas pro-democracia esta castiga a
la secesión la subversión el terrorismo
y la colusión con poderes extranjeros
hasta con cadena perpetua beijing dice
que la ley trae estabilidad pero los
oponentes aseguran que limita la
libertad de expresión y va en contra del
esquema de un país dos sistemas
la hasta ahora llamada variante andina
de kobe 19 responsable de la mayoría de
los contagios en perú y de un tercio de
los casos en chile y argentina- fue
bautizada lambda por la organización
mundial de la salud y entra dentro de
las denominadas variantes de interés que
son aquellas que tienen una mayor
capacidad de transmisión del virus esta
variante fue detectada por primera vez
en agosto de 2020 y su principal
territorio de contagio ha sido américa
latina' rodrigo ciudad no tiene los
detalles
hasta el momento la conocíamos como
variante andina
ahora la un se la ha denominado como el
lambda no sólo es un cambio de nombre
lanza pasa ahora a considerarse como
variante de interés una denominación
bajo la que se encuentra en otras seis
variantes en todo el mundo la primera y
más leve de las tres clases de variantes
que clasifica la o ms seguida de las
variantes preocupantes en última
instancia a la denominación alta
consecuencia que por el momento no
cuenta con ninguna variante registrada
blanda no es una variante nueva fue
detectada por primera vez en perú en
agosto de 2020 pero tras un largo
monitoreo la o ms señala su mayor
capacidad de transmisión comunitaria el
organismo estudia si lambda podría tener
mutaciones que la hacen más contagiosa y
resistente a los anticuerpos el campo de
acción de esta variante es
principalmente américa latina' en perú
la variante supone ya el 81 por ciento
de los casos monitoreados desde abril en
chile representa asimismo el 32 por
ciento de los casos reportados en los
últimos 60 días similar a la incidencia
de la variante brasileña en este país
argentina por su parte informó de una
incidencia del 37 por ciento entre el 2
de abril y el 19 de mayo ahora la oms se
deberá estudiar si lanza podría dar el
paso a variante de preocupación
en otras noticias aumenta la
preocupación por la detención de
críticos al gobierno de nicaragua ya son
16 los arrestados entre ellos 4
precandidatos presidenciales políticos
activistas ex guerrilleros y
funcionarios del sector privado todo
esto bajo la ley de defensa que entró en
vigor en diciembre del año pasado y de
cara a las elecciones presidenciales de
noviembre para analizar lo que está
ocurriendo allí nos acompaña josé miguel
vivanco director para las américas de
human rightswatch señor vivanco
bienvenido france24 como esta ley de
defensa está cambiando el panorama
electoral y el poder del presidente
daniel ortega
en el poder de ortega y de su esposa la
señora murillo es hoy día en nicaragua y
de las ella un tiempo total ellos
controlan el congreso controlan el poder
judicial el ministerio público la
policía y el ejército y están dispuestos
a usar ese poder a pesar del escándalo
que genera a nivel nacional y a nivel
internacional
el objetivo es limpiar la cancha y
presentarse finalmente a unas elecciones
presidenciales el 7 de noviembre sin que
exista un competidor que sea capaz de
derrotar a ortega es principalmente el
objetivo y aunque parezca esto
absolutamente
grotesco algo a lo que no estábamos
acostumbrados de américa latina eso es
lo que está haciendo gradual y
sistemáticamente uno a uno todos los
días que tienen alguien importante de la
sociedad civil con el propósito de
generar el terror y en el resto de la
población y entender cuáles son las
reglas del juego el 15 de junio la oea
aprobó la resolución con la que condenó
los arrestos y los acosos que tan
efectivo puede ser este texto para
generar presión internacional frente a
lo que ocurre en el país además una
resolución que no todos los países
firmaron
mira esa resolución es importante no
sólo por el texto que exige la
liberación inmediata de todos aquellos
que han sido detenidos condena estos
hechos sino también por el número de
países que la prueba en 26 países de la
región es un número importante es un
número alto lamentablemente argentina y
méjico se abstuvieron y firmaron un
documento alternativo que caen en
enormes contradicciones es realmente un
retroceso habla de la no injerencia a
los asuntos internos y sugiere que hay
instituciones democráticas a las que hay
que respetar en nicaragua lo cual es
absolutamente falso es importante este
pronunciamiento por sí solo no va a
cambiar las cosas pero es un primer paso
especialmente si el objetivo es por
ejemplo lograr que naciones unidas se
ocupe de esta situación y que el
secretario general de naciones unidas
tome cartas en el asunto para eso es
importante que exista una mayoría
regional que condena estos hechos en
naciones unidas ese pronunciamiento
regional
tiene peso señor vivanco los familiares
de los llamados presos políticos
denunciaron violencia excesiva por parte
de los agentes y en ocasiones han
asegurado que no poseen orden judicial
para allanar las casas de los detenidos
además de esposarlos y golpearlos qué
instancia debería evitar que estos
hechos irregulares ocurran cuando el
gobierno está a favor de las detenciones
no hay ninguna instancia a nivel
nacional en nicaragua que pueda evitar
estos hechos los abusos las torturas los
tratos crueles y la falta total del
debido proceso imagínate que cristiana
chamorro está secuestrada en su propio
hogar no le dejan salir de su propio
cuarto el resto de la casa está invadida
por agentes armados no tiene acceso a su
abogado
apenas se puede comunicar con un
familiar que lo visita que la visita el
resto de los detenidos están en 50
circunstancias similares es decir acá no
hay debido proceso' acá se han inventado
procedimientos judiciales única
únicamente con el propósito de
amedrentarlos y detener los secuestran
los
lamentablemente desgraciadamente no hay
esta gente está en total
como ya dije indefensión en desamparo si
no hay una reacción internacional fuerte
mucho más fuerte de lo que hasta ahora
hemos podido presenciar esto va a
continuar pues los capturados han sido
acusados de actuar contra el gobierno al
incitar a la injerencia extranjera
de cara a las elecciones de noviembre
donde ortega busca una nueva reelección
con este panorama cómo se logran las
garantías de justicia y transparencia
que se piden para los comicios
no hay posibilidades de celebrar
comicios transparentes mínimamente
creíbles de las actuales condiciones y
esto es realmente una burla acá se están
violando normas elementales no sólo
respecto a lo que es derechos humanos
sino también normas y principios básicos
de una democracia representativa de
principios que están consagrados en la
carta democrática
ortega está abiertamente violando estas
estas normas estos principios y
realmente digamos estos procedimientos
no tienen ninguna legitimidad lo único
que cabe la condena y la presión
internacional señor vivanco pues muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
acompañarnos estamos muy pendientes de
lo que pueda ocurrir en nicaragua en
otras noticias tras más de semana y
media de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales perú sigue sin
conocer al ganador de la contienda que
deberá asumir la presidencia el 28 de
julio y aunque el martes terminó el
escrutinio por parte de la oficina de
procesos electorales queda una venta
al candidato de izquierda pedro castillo
de 44.000 58 votos sobre la candidata de
derecha keiko fujimori es el jurado
nacional de elecciones el que deberá
declarar al ganador luego de resolver
las solicitudes de nulidad de
impugnaciones de mesas solicitadas por
ambos candidatos
tras 10 años de ausencia el ex
presidente de costa de marfil laurent
gbagbo regresa a su país en las próximas
horas la corte penal internacional lo
absolvió de sus cuatro cargos por
crímenes de lesa humanidad aunque
todavía debe enfrentarse a la justicia
de su país ya que en 2019 fue condenado
a 20 años de cárcel por corrupción el 31
de marzo de 2021 la corte penal
internacional confirmó la decisión de
absolver a logan van gogh de crímenes
contra la humanidad
la sala de apelaciones revoca todas las
condiciones restantes para la liberación
de bajó tras esta sentencia
aunque lo que está en el centro del
procedimiento judicial que comenzó en
enero de 2016 es el conflicto entre los
dos políticos los hechos que forman
parte de la investigación se remontan a
finales de 2010 tras unas elecciones
presidenciales muy reñidas las tensiones
entre bad boy utara aumentaron cuando la
comisión electoral de costa de marfil le
dio la victoria al asad para con el 54,1
por ciento de los votos
algo respaldado por la onu pero estos
resultados fueron invalidados al día
siguiente por el consejo constitucional
que proclamó la victoria de laurent
gbagbo iniciando la incertidumbre que
sumió al país en el caos por cinco meses
los partidarios de los dos bandos se
enfrentaron y la violencia derivada
acabó con la vida de más de tres mil
personas pero la bomba bono no cedió ni
un centímetro de terreno junto a sus
seguidores a gameplay wood fue acusado
de ordenar violaciones y asesinatos de
sus opositores en abril de 2011 fue
detenido con la ayuda del ejército
francés y trasladado a la haya donde se
enfrentó a cuatro cargos por crímenes de
lesa humanidad los cuales negó tras un
juicio de tres años en el que declararon
82 testigos las pruebas con trabajo y
bloqueo se consideraron insuficientes y
los dos hombres fueron absueltos en
enero de 2019 decisión confirmada por la
sala de apelación de la cpi en 2021
la ong 'save the children' alertó que
cientos de menores migrantes y
refugiados no acompañados que viajan por
países de europa están sufriendo abusos
violencia sin precedentes o son
rechazados ilegalmente en las fronteras
el texto denuncia que en montón en
francia- los niños aseguraron haber sido
encerrados en contenedores y que se
modificó su fecha de nacimiento para que
pudieran ser llevados de regreso a
italia
y finalizamos en china que lanzó con
éxito al espacio la misión se new 12 con
tres astronautas a bordo que
participarán en los trabajos de su
estación espacial tiangong a los
astronautas estarán tres meses en órbita
y su principal tarea según la agencia
china del espacio es verificar las
principales tecnologías para construir y
operar la la estación que el país
asiático prevé tener lista para 2022
con estas imágenes nos despedimos a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía pueden
ampliar todas las noticias en nuestra
web france24 puntocom
[Música]